madame monsieur bonsoir c'est un film
que l'on n'attendait pas qui a reçu la
palme d'or du 52e festival de cannes
rosetta des cinéastes belges luc et jean
pierre dardenne le jury présidé par le
canadien cronenberg a pris cette
décision à l'unanimité
double triomphe pour aux états puisque
son actrice a reçu aussi le prix
d'interprétation féminine
michel vial benoît vers 7h de look et
jean pierre dardenne une palme d'or
inattendue s'il en est la première en
tout cas pour la belgique
loin des strass et des paillettes le
jury du 52e festival a couronné un film
âpre un drame social proche du
documentaire
je vais essayer d'être aussi simple que
le film qu'on essaie de faire et un
jours merci beaucoup d'avoir émis
rosetta rosetta qui vont également à sa
comédienne émilie dequenne le prix
d'interprétation féminine
pardon monde l'a déjà je voudrais
embrasser ma famille qui fait
certainement pas la division
un prix décerné ex-aequo à une autre
comédienne non-professionnels séverine
cannes l interprète du second
triomphateurs de la soirée l'humanité de
bruno dumont également grand prix du
jury et dont le comédien emmanuel
schotté obtient le prix d'interprétation
masculine qui est important c'est que ce
cinéma n'en existe encore cette espèce
de folie de qui font que les sina sondés
sont des hommes qui marchent devant les
publics et pas derrière et qui qui
invente des mondes et qui tendent les
mains aux spectateurs je ne comprends
rien en fait on avait tout faux dans nos
prédictions mais et pour cause parce que
vraiment je crois que le jury s'est
complètement bourré sans que ce
cauchemar dans la croix le maire je suis
très concerné
surtout pour les comédiens je pense pas
que dans les films qui ont été primés il
y en a qui vont vraiment sortir les gens
de chez eux pour leur donner envie
d'aller au cinéma
exception faite pour pedro almodovar
prix de la mise en scène est pourtant
plébiscité par les spectateurs et les
critiques
le jury 99 en effet résolument jouer la
marginalité
en primant un cinéma certes novateur
dans sa forme mary 2 voire indigeste sur
le fond david cronenberg dont la voix
est prépondérante demeure fidèle à son
goût pour la provocation et à la couleur
grise d'une fan siècle en quête de
repères
un jeu dangereux conçue sans doute au
détriment d'un public pour qui le cinéma
constitue encore le dernier remède
contre la morosité